hey guys Adam sacks here hi Adam hi Adam
Hi Sona hi Matt I'm sorry but uh I came
here with some information oh yeah it's
my you know Duty as a member of the team
to bring news I think that's pertinent
um I have a you know fiduciary duty
civic duty to the to the company I don't
I am terrified at this moment I don't
know what he's gonna say and I do Matt
knows what it is and it's really
unfortunate but I had to bring it to you
guys which is that Matt has a new
podcast and uh I think you're going to
want to understand what it is what yeah
you have a podcast well a new podcast
yeah okay so I just hesitate to even put
this in your lap but I have a new
podcast called Mall walking oh well
walking what are you talking about well
my buddy Mark mcconville and I we just
record ourselves walking through malls
uh-huh okay it's called Mall walking
she's like no g at the end there's an
apostrophe yeah yeah this is a spin-off
of another podcast called pistol shrimps
radio where we would call play-by-play
on women's rec league basketball even
though we don't know anything about
sports but that League ended and we
stopped going I love that idea because
I've been doing that for years I've been
trying to do color commentate uh when I
watch sports and television with other
people and they become enraged because
it's all just nonsense yeah so that that
one's in the Wheelhouse I don't
understand this mall walking thing well
we just take two microphones and we go
walk through a different Mall each
episode and talk about them all you're
holding the microphone we record it in
the mall as we walk through the mall do
people look at you yeah is it awkward
yeah do you go shopping no you just walk
through the mall yeah
okay those are first of all impressed
with the speed of those questions
you know you were just firing off
questions that was fantastic but really
I I'm not gonna lie I love them all and
I I like this really I thought for sure
I was gonna get lambasted well maybe
it's time that I spoke then
you are a new father you have an infant
at home you can barely make it in here
to do this podcast and I'm always
hearing uh he can't really make it in
you know he can't really no he's got
cause the baby well this little girl no
we can't oh he's feeling a little under
the weather you're constantly barely
making it in here for this podcast which
by the way is a juggernaut
and now you've carved out time for Mall
walking apostrophe with your friend Brit
goodly
this is I would never put Mall
walking ahead of this podcast well how
could you have time I there's no time
first of all does your wife know that
you've carved out this silly podcast
well my wife was in was on the
basketball team where we did the
play-by-play so she's in a sense
responsible for this what do you mean
well because that we would go to her
games and call the play-by-play that was
pistol shrimps radio but now this is
pistol shrimps radio presents Mall
walking so you've told your wife I can't
I gotta go I know the baby has colic and
I know that you're running a fever and
the uh the the dishwasher is overflowing
because it's broken
um I gotta go because it's time for Mall
walking apostrophe with Chaz bilnick
look when you put it this way yeah this
is this is a this is a terrible you've
created a huge I mean Sona do you go to
the food court like do you eat it like a
sparrow we did start oh that would
justify it huh Sona
last whatever we went and we he my buddy
Mark got a Dairy Queen Blizzard by the
way I'm determined not to know his name
it's Mark McConnell okay I got it got it
what is it Sam lip shine
we also got kicked out of a Macy's why
well we went to the Eagle Rock Plaza and
their Macy's is like a cave of Darkness
it's just falling apart yeah it is it's
scary yeah that's rough which malls have
you gotten to Eagle Rock Plaza okay
Burbank town center and that's all we've
done also this thing's probably only
going to come out once a month okay
again
your time is precious yeah you this is
Fitness though can you do a live
recording
can I come you can come no you don't
have to be alive of course no no no no
no no I am not losing my team yeah we
can't miss tomorrow's session we're
gonna miss it because we're going to the
shops at Santa Anita I don't know hey I
want to go to that one for sure we have
can you explain how Show Business works
okay yeah
the water flows down from the top this
thing this podcast we have here
no I don't want to be on okay I don't
want to try and compete with Whiz
backman
let me tell you something Buster Brown
we've got lightning in a bottle we've
got a tiger by the tail with this Conan
O'Brien needs a friend and you're off
Mall walking yeah and now you want to go
too Sonos do you wear like track suits
are you is it a fitness thing well we
are getting Fitness because we're we're
marking our steps and we're walking
around aren't you afraid of like
we're doing this at 11 A.M on a school
day oh yeah yeah no teenagers cut school
to go to the mall I hope you're attacked
by teenagers
I really do I hope I
by tomorrow
driving
answering to the local news and they say
big big trouble over at the Eagle Rock
wakatorium
look normally Matt Gourley and co-host
Xander baxton
we're brutally beaten by a gang of 11
year old children who were cutting
School normally I'd be insulted by this
but I'm actually with you this is a poor
excuse for a podcast if you listen you
listen to your own risk it's stupid it's
dumb it'll probably rarely come out
check it out on Spotify and podcast
wherever you listen Stitcher can you go
to the
that was my Mall yeah and that's the um
bathroom Pine small from yeah Back to
the Future it is okay Sona is it not
true that uh you used to cut School
sometimes I never oh you did cool I had
perfect attendance from kindergarten to
12th grade yes suck on that whoa suck on
that I was really proud of my perfect
attendance it's the only thing I did
right I was in school
well that that's refreshing you didn't
yeah because I know that you you went
through kind of a wild child period I I
did and that was uh you were Rizzo from
Greece I was but I showed up to school I
mean I'd get a lot of detention because
I wasn't like really there but I and
also you had a temper probably you
probably lost it on people I did yeah I
had an issue I I don't know if you would
believe this but I did have a problem
with authority and so I was Bingo now
then off yeah well uh now then off but
I'll uh we'll do puential Hills Mall
together you come on Mall walking I'll
show you where I used to work I love it
at the watch store yeah the watch store
which isn't there anymore all right well
check it out mom walk in Matt gorley zap
sternik
coming to a mall uh near you getting a
lot of Ambient sound and muttering it's
not a good podcast yeah yeah well you've
done your job promoting it
check it out everybody check it out